>> Bret: WE'LL GET REACTION FROM
THE DEIDRA.
GOOD EVENING.
>> IT IS A STAND OUT REPORT.
THE MAIN DATA AND MARKING THE 92
SECOND MONTH OF INCREASE.
AND MOST WERE IN HEALTH CARE AND
FOLLOW WOULD BY RETAIL AND
PROFESSIONAL SERVICE AND LEISURE
AND HOSPITALITY.
AND UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICAN FELL TO A NEW
LOW, 5.9 PERCENT.
AND FEMALE JOB SEEKERS 3.4
PERCENT AND EASIER START FOR
RECENT GRADUATES, TOO.
JOB OPENINGS ARE IN A TWO DECADE
HIGH.
AND IT IS DIFFICULT TO FIND
HIGHLY SKILLED WORKER CONDITIONS
AND ONCE THEY FIND TALENT, THEY
HAVE TO PAY MORE TO KEEP
EMPLOYEES ON BOARD.
THAT INCREASES, AND ECONOMIST
WAS WONDERING HOW IT IS GROWING.
AND AS OF TODAY THAT IS CHANGING
AND MONTH ON MONTH AND SHOW THAT
THE FORECAST.
IT SIGNALS THE BALANCE FOR